rowdy a deep conversation prior to you
coming on about drug testing did were
they doing that back when you were
swimming where there was somebody who
had to watch you take a urine test I
didn't have it that bad then nobody
actually went into the bathroom to watch
it but yeah there was drug testing we
did it all the time and we only did it
after the major meets we didn't have an
ongoing tests throughout the year we
just did it at the Olympics World
Championships etc as far as do we hear
about doping when it comes to swimming I
know that the whole Russian
track-and-field team is not allowed to
go to Rio but as far as at the great by
the way yeah but attached to swimming
the East Germans used to do this but it
can you tell could you tell when you
would see an opponent if somebody was
using back when you were swimming
absolutely no you know no question about
it damn when I when I was swimming I was
sort at the height of that East German
cheating machine and mostly it came from
the women I don't know why but somehow
it didn't apply to the men even though I
think they were cheating as well they
just didn't figure out how to do it as
well with a min as the women but yeah it
still goes on there's no doubt about it
um I have my suspicions on who and where
but even now can tell you with women
even now oh yeah man it happens I mean
IIIi think we're baring our head in the
sand if we don't think it's out there
but I do feel like overall our sport
swimming is much cleaner than some of
the other sports in the olympic games
and even in the professional sports
obviously i just don't see it as much I
don't have my eyes and ears to the
ground on on the other sports as much as
swimming obviously but I just don't see
it in swimming especially here in our
country I just feel very confident about
our country and and where we're at is
being clean but what is the eye test
well you you can see it's not so much
the eye test physically then it's what
it's the history behind an athlete and
what they did before and where they're
at now the dramatic changes in x over 1
year or two year period and at a certain
age you can also see some sign them in
the old days you could see you know
women with mustaches and deep voices and
and hair and their big foreheads those
were the steroid days and you can't tell
quite as much physically today because
of the micro dosing that happens and and
that is much more difficult to tell from
ana physical appearance I just base it
on the history of what they've done in
the sport up to now wasn't there the
Irish swimmer female swimmer last name
smith i believe yep michelle smith back
in 96 ended up winning couple gold
medals in those games in atlanta and
then later on you know got kicked out of
the sport because she got caught
cheating we're talking to rowdy Gaines
the NBC olympic swimming analyst i know
that you were probably in the small
group i believe after london and you
didn't think that Michael Phelps was
going to be able to stay retired it do I
remember that correctly that you said
Dan Hicks that you you didn't you didn't
believe it that was one of the last
questions that Dan asked me on the
broadcast when Michael summoned he asked
me if I thought he was going to stay
retired I just didn't believe so I
listen when you're when you have that
magic in your only back then you're 27
years of age why not keep utilizing he's
a competitor he loves it it's not like
he's a boxer Danny's not like getting
out there getting beat up or footballer
there's such a huge risk of injury he's
got the rest of his life to live and
when you're at or near the top um I say
keep going you know I mean and I just
didn't feel like he had left everything
in the pool in 2012 I don't think he was
happy back then I think he was just
fighting to just stay alive in 2012 and
so many things have changed over the
last four years in his life to where
he's just in a great state right now in
this great state of mind anyway and he
wanted to go
one last round yeah you guys have said
that on the broadcast and and and I've
been around Michael and it just he
wasn't open he wasn't having fun it
didn't seem like that he was he was
wired to handle this but it felt like
rehab may have opened his eyes into who
he really is or who he wants to be and
having his baby and it I don't know of
how he's going to do in Rio but I think
he's going to have a good time in Rio if
that makes sense absolutely you're spot
on Dan I mean is it took the trials have
been well documented that he's had the
last four years but I think he's gained
so much perspective think about us did I
mean think about when we were mid-20s I
didn't have my life figured out I didn't
really know I was you know doing some
things I probably wasn't very proud of
but as you start to mature especially
fatherhood you know that just changes
your life so much to it changes things
dramatically and dude man for 12 years
all he did was eat breathe and drink
swimming there was a time than that
between two thousand and two thousand
eight for eight years he was only out of
the water three days in eight years and
that that can take its toll not so much
physically the physical part yeah that's
true but it's emotional part and the
mental part and I think after two
thousand eight the guy wanted to play
you know he wanted to try to enjoy
himself a little bit and and I think it
just got you know things got too tough
on them and in 2012 was rough but boy I
tell ya fatherhood has definitely
changed him I've never seen him happier
I've known him for 16 years and I've
talked to Michael Moore the last year
Dan that I did the previous 15 we look
at athletes in and when they age when
they're at their peak right like i watch
the the women's swimming Missy Franklin
was a star in London and you thought
maybe these were going to be her
Olympics but it feels like they've
already passed her by and you got Katie
ledecky there so the difference between
when women sort of hit their peak and
when the men do how is there a big
difference in that age there is there's
no doubt that the average age on the
team four years ago was 26
2326 from in 23 for women so there's no
doubt that women skew a little younger
but that's changed because money is more
involved in the sport now but women go
through changes i have four daughters
man and and you know they go through
these physical changes and sometimes you
just have to learn to adapt natalie
coughlin 33 she adapted you remember
amanda beard at 16 in atlanta point for
two or three years after atlantis she
was terrible she came back learned to
adapt to her new body physically
mentally emotionally and she and it went
on to win another gold medal you know
four years later so it it it's this
change in life and it's not for Missy
it's not just changes physically but
it's changes outside of the pool and she
turned pro you know she's so nice dude
that she has this this feeling of guilt
with obligations to all her sponsors and
and I think that that's taken a toll but
boy she showed me a lot of heart last
night man when she made that toner
freestyle she's someone an individual
now if you could sneak in passion bucket
tonight or tomorrow that'd be kind of
nice rowdy is a shout out to this show
you know like in bucket yes like
somebody's passion bucket is full you
know when somebody wins you can say oh
look at look at his face his passion
bucket is full I'm writing it down
passion bucket is full got it yes it's
on done dude I like it I like it I like
I was going to watch anyway rowdy but
I'm definitely gonna watch now I'm gonna
DVR tell a lie Hicks he's doing a great
job it's a great great watch great
listen with you guys thank you so much
they appreciate seeing real yep see in a
couple of weeks it's a rowdy Gaines
that's a dude who is excited when he
calls a race he is into it the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you